Speaker 1: I'm going to play for you a brief
sample of testimony from Kerry Lake's supposed
expert. And this was a guy who was going to
help overturn the election or something. And
we already looked at how her lawyers don't seem
super competent. And then now here is an expert
and it all goes bad very, very quickly.
Speaker 2: Goes in a door. Number three
goes down to make tech. The much more
sensitive. Tabulators, according to you,
would not count it. It would then go
to duplication. It would be duplicated,
then it would be tabulated. Is that your
understanding of the elections in Maricopa County?
Your technical description is not possible.
I apologize. I wasn't attempting to give
a technical was really I was just saying
what happens based on your testimony? So
you're saying in that scenario that voter
who wanted to vote for Kerry would never have
that vote tabulated? Is that your testimony?
My testimony is that a shrink to fit setting
would rely at the application level, which would
reside on the air mass, which Mr. Garrett just
testified since the print job to the printer.
Speaker 1: Therefore, aren't
you guys understanding this?
Speaker 2: It can't be accidental as all the
employees that man, the EMS, are trained,
whether it's accidental or inadvertent. We gave
the two options. Please allow me to answer the
ask the question. Allow you to answer whether
it's accidental or inadvertent. If the shrink
to fit 19 inch ballot has to be duplicated.
Once it's duplicated, would it be tabulated?
To your understanding. There are two
technical ways that that image would be
there. None of the ways, you know, it's not even
possible. That's not a sponsor of your honor.
Speaker 1: So what a waste of time. This is
what courts are now being bogged down with.
Here's another moment where the witness says that
Mike Pillow has been, I guess, paying for some
of his travel. Everything about this is crazy.
Speaker 2: I've been home in Missouri. Missouri,
and. Was your travel from Alabama to Missouri
paid for by someone other than yourself?
Yes, sir. And who paid for that? That
would, I assume, would be Glendale not.
All their travel was arranged. He asked me
to speak at the event and I spoke. And yeah.
Speaker 1: So the expert is funded
by pillow and speaking at Mike Pillow
events. Disastrous experts, disastrous
lawyers. Carey Lake every day is claiming,
like they're getting major legal victories in
these hearings. They are not. Katie Hobbs will
be the governor of Arizona. Mark my words, I'm not
a betting man, but that's something I would bet on